just freaking come out already
no not you rock the game I'm Gabe who
writer and here's hoping that this final
trailer for the final game in the Arkham
series means we finally get to play on
that sweet batty goodness this is
hashtag news
[Music]
this game has been super delayed already
and this trailer has me begging for its
release begging begging so why was it
delayed a rumor has it that the creators
of the game were told that the storyline
was way too dark and that they'd have to
change it okay newer rumors though
suggest that the dark storyline has been
allowed to stay which yeah duh it's
Batman what do you want even the kids
Animated Series still killed off Barbara
Gordon I mean in a dream but still all
right the new trailer lots of stuff
going on in this one and it's all good
in the Red Hood sure Red Hood is in the
actual trailer but there are still
rumors that he'll be in the game and I
really want to make that joke two-face
is back but since he was barely in
Arkham City and he's barely in this
trailer I can't tell if he'll actually
be in the game much either I guess you
could call it a toy cost
oh boy cause Oracle is either watching
the movie Contagion
or she's studying some sort of chemical
strain of something I'm not gonna
pretend I know about all the sciency
stuff but in any storyline where
scarecrow is one of the primary villains
you can bet there's probably a new
strain of fear toxin out there ready to
get everyone high on nightmares robots
full of some sort of bright green
kombucha liquid get their asses handed
to them by the bat team and while we
could maybe guess that their liquid guts
could have something to do with the
Scarecrow's fear toxin he's not really
the kind of freak that knows how to do
advanced robotics maybe he wrote a book
or something comic book stories where
anyone can be a brilliant scientist now
we've got a lot more looks at the
mysterious Arkham Knight himself aka the
bizarro metallo anti Batman this guy
looks awesome now we see yeah he's got a
freaking army with him the fact that he
clearly has a bunch of soldiers on his
side makes his identity even harder to
guess who has that kind of clout are
they just random ER scenaries or
something like a leftover League of
Shadows that need a new leader I don't
know but he's got tanks also I'm loving
the white eyes which remind me of those
times when Batman activates that AI
sonar thing he uses whenever it's
convenient
Ezreal is in there just an easter egg in
Arkham City in this game he's clearly
gonna play a bigger role I can never
decide if I like this guy you know yeah
are you good are you bad it stopped
being so vague about everything okay
okay here's the best freakin part about
this trailer from the looks of it
Rocksteady Studios took a page out of
GTA 5 playbook and you're gonna be able
to swap characters but not just a random
weirdos okay you're gonna get the
players Robin Nightwing Catwoman Oracle
maybe I hope not the trailer even says
for those
you want to let your inner freak flag
fly you can play as Harley freaking quit
calm down though I said play as Harley
Quinn with do us a favor and hit
subscribe down below if you liked the
video we like making the video you might
as well like the video and subscribe and
leave a comment about your favorite part
of the trailer mine was probably Robins
metal pole the staff that thing use it
the bow not pull as always I'm Gabe Howe
writer and wait what is that is that
fear toxin know the game is delayed
again
well my nipples have faces oh no I
pooped someone else's pants
[Music]